[Music]
to start things off here i'm curious if
you could start by explaining what you
think are some of the most important
problems in the world today
well first of all thank you for
for having me um gosh what are the most
important problems in the world i think
we have uh the challenge of climate
change i think we have uh the challenge
of uh inequality
uh where we're having we i think we have
the challenge that uh
economic growth and development is
happening unevenly so i should say that
the inequality question i think is most
in inequality within countries
but to some extent also between
countries and this idea of uneven
development is that some countries are
surging ahead and some parts of the
world are potentially being left behind
um i think we have other social
political questions but those i'm not
qualified to talk about those i don't
really spend my time i'm not a
sociologist or a political scientist but
i think we do have some
social political challenges too we have
climate change we have
social inequality we have the ways in
which
different societies are progressing at
at different rates so
given these issues in the world what do
you think it is that that humanity
really needs to understand or get right
in this century given given these
problems
yeah but by the way i should also before
i dive into that also say even though we
have these uh problems and challenges we
also have incredible opportunities quite
frankly to
for breakthrough progress and prosperity
and
uh to solve some of these issues and
quite frankly do things that are going
to transform humanity for the better so
these are
challenges at a time of i think uh
unprecedented opportunity and
possibility so i also make sure we we we
acknowledge both sides of that issue
i think i think these uh uh
you know in terms of what we need to do
about these challenges i think part of
it is also just uh quite frankly facing
them head on i think the question of uh
climate change is one that is an
existential challenge that we just need
to
face head head-on and quite frankly get
on with doing everything we can
both to mitigate the effects of climate
change and also quite frankly to start
to adapt how our society our economy
works uh to again
address what is essentially an
existential challenge i think that what
we do in the next 10 years is going to
matter more than what we do in the 10
years after that so there's some urgency
uh to the to the climate uh changing
climate risk question
i think with regards to the issue of um
inequality i think this is one that you
know is also within our capacity to
address i think it's important to keep
in mind that i think the
you know capitalism and the market
economies that we've had and we do have
have been unbelievably successful in
creating growth and economic prosperity
uh for the world in in most places where
they've been applied
but i think you know particularly in
recent years i think
we've also started to see that in fact
there's been growth in inequality partly
because the structure of our economy is
changing and we can get into that
conversation
so in fact some people are doing
phenomenally well and others are not and
some places are doing phenomenally well
and some other places are not i mean
it's not lost on me for example lucas
that even if you look at an economy that
like the united states something like
two-thirds of our economic output comes
out of six percent of the counties in
the country that's a that's an
inequality of place in addition to the
inequalities that we have of people so i
think we have to we have to uh tackle
the issue of inequality are quite quite
head-on and you know
unless you do something it it has the
potential for getting to get worse uh
before it gets better the way our
economy now works and this is quite
different by the way than what it might
have looked like even as recently as 25
years ago which is
uh most of the economic activity uh a
function of the sectors that are driving
economic growth a function of the types
of enterprises and companies that are
driving economic growth they've tended
to be much more today than they were 25
years ago to be fairly regionally
concentrated
and in particular places so some of
those places include silicon valley and
other places whereas if you had looked
for example 25 years ago
where you might have seen the kind of
sectors and companies that were doing
well were much more geographically
distributed so you had more economic
activity
coming out of more places across the
country than you do now so this is just
again a function of not that you know
anybody designed it to be that way but
just a function of the sectors and
companies and the way our economy works
a related factor by the way is even the
even the inequality question is also a
function of how
you know the economy works i mean it
used to be the case that um
you know whenever we had economic growth
and productivity growth it also resulted
in job growth and wage growth
that's been true for a very long time
but i think in recent years as and
depending how you counted the last 25
years ago or so
when we have productivity growth it
doesn't it doesn't lift up wages as much
as it used to uh again it's a function
of the structure of the of the of the
economy uh in fact some of the work
we've been doing and other economists
have been doing uh is actually been to
look at this
so-called declining labor share
and i think a way to understand that
declining labor share is to think about
the fact that
um
uh you know if you if you had to set up
a factory say you know 200 years ago
most of the inputs into how that factory
worked were all labor inputs so the
labor share of economic activity is much
higher but over time you know if you're
setting up a factory today
sure you have labor input but you also
have a lot of capital input in terms of
the equipment the machinery the robots
and so forth so the actual
labor portion of you know of in as a
share of the inputs is being grained
down steadily and that's just part of
how our structure of our economy is
changing so all of these effects are
some of what is leading to
uh
uh to some of the uh in inequality that
we see so
before we drill
more deeply into climate change and
inequality are there any other issues
that that you would add as some of the
most crucial problems or questions for
the 21st century
the structure of our global economy is
changing and i think you know it's now
getting caught up also in kind of
geopolitics i'm not a geopolitical
expert but it's it's not lost
from a global economy standpoint uh that
in fact we now have and will have two
very large economies the united states
and china and china is a very large
economy
and
it's not just a source of uh
you know exports or things that we buy
from them but it's also uh intertangled
with say the us and other countries
economically in terms of
uh uh monetary uh and debt and lending
and so forth but it's also uh a large
economy itself which is going to have
its own consumption so we now have for
the first time
two very large uh global economies and
so how that works in a geopolitical
sense is one of the complications of the
of the 21st century so i think that's an
important uh issue uh others who are
more qualified to talk about geopolitics
can
delve into that one but that's clearly
in the mix as part of the uh challenges
of the 21st
21st century we also of course are going
to have to think about uh the role of
technology in our economies in our
society partly because technology can be
a force of massive productivity growth
innovation and good and all of that but
at the same time we know that many of
these technologies uh uh raise new
questions about
uh privacy about uh you know even
how we think about information
disinformation so i think you know if
you were to write the list of the the
the questions we're going to need to
navigate uh in the coming
uh decades of the 21st century it's it's
it's a it's a bt list uh it's a climate
changes at the top of that list in my
view uh you know inequalities is on that
list these questions of geopolitics are
on that list the role that technology is
going to play uh is on that list uh and
then also you know some of these social
uh questions that we now need to wrestle
with
issues of social justice and not just
economic justice but also social justice
so we have a pretty rich
uh
challenge list even while at the same
time that we have these extraordinary
opportunities so
in the realms of climate change and
inequality
and
these new
geopolitical situations and tensions
that are arising how do you see the role
of incentives
pushing these systems and problems in
certain directions and how it is that we
come up with solutions to them given the
the the power and motivational force of
incentives
well i think incentives play an
important role so take the issue of
climate change for example i think one
of the failures of our
economics and economic systems is we've
never quite priced carbon uh and we've
never quite built that into our
incentive systems our economic system so
we have a price for it so that when we
we put up you know carbon dioxide into
the atmosphere and all and so forth
there's no economic price for that uh or
uh or incentives a set of incentives not
to do that we haven't done enough in
that regard so that's an area where
incentives would actually make make a
big difference in the case of uh
inequality i think this one's way more
complicated beyond just incentives but
i'll point to something that is in the
realm of incentives with regards to
inequality so for example take the way
uh we were talking earlier about
the importance of labor and capital uh
in our capital inputs that i mean
capitalism uh the money necessarily just
the actual capital equipment and
machines and so forth in our system
uh we've built a set of incentives for
example that encourage
companies to invest in in in capital
infrastructure you know capital
equipment
they can write it off for example we
encourage investments in r d for example
and tax incentives to do that which is
wonderful because we need that for
the productivity and growth and
innovation of our economy but we haven't
done anything
nearly enough or equivalent to to that
those kinds of incentives with regards
to investments in human capital so you
could imagine a much more concerted
effort to
create incentives for
companies and others to invest in human
capital uh and be able to write off
investments in skilling for example to
be able to do that at the equivalent
scale to the incentives we have for
other forms of investment like in
capital or in r d so that's an example
of where we haven't done enough on the
incentive uh front and we we should
so but i think there's more to be done
than just incentives for the uh for for
the inequality question but in those
kinds of incentives would help i should
tell you uh lucas one of the things that
we spent the last um
year or so looking at is
trying to understand how the
social contract
has evolved in the 21st century so far
so we actually looked at for example the
you know the roughly you know uh 23 of
the oecd countries uh there's about 37
or 38 of them but we looked about 23 of
them in in detail just to understand how
the social contract
uh had evolved and here because
you know we're not sociologists we
looked at the social contract in in
really three ways right
how people participate in the economy as
workers because that's part of
uh you know when people work hard and
public exchanges that they get jobs and
they get income and wages and training
so
people participating as workers is an
important part of the social contract
people participating as consumers and
households
who consume products and services
and then people as savers who are kind
of saving money for future you know for
their kids or for their future etc and
when you look at those three
aspects of the social contract in the
21st century so far it's really quite
stunning so take the worker piece of
that for example what has happened is
that you know across most countries
we've actually grown jobs despite you
know the recession you know of i guess
the recession 2001 but also the bigger
one in 2008
uh we've actually grown jobs so there
are actually more jobs now than they
were
uh you know at the start of the 21st
century
however
uh what has happened is that many of
those jobs uh don't pay as well uh so
the wage wages associated with that
pictures actually shifted quite a bit
the other thing about
what's happened with work is it's
becoming a little bit more
uh brittle in the fact that uh you know
job certainty has certainly gone down uh
you know there's much more income and
you know wage variability so we've
created more fragile jobs relatively to
what we had at the start of the 21st
century so you could say
for workers
uh it's a mixed story right
job growth yes wage growth not so much
uh job certainty and and and job
fragility has gone up
when you look at people as consumers and
households
it also paints
an interesting story and the picture you
see there is the fact that
you know
if households and consumers are
consuming things like uh uh think about
you know buying cars or white goods
products or electronics or uh basically
things that are globally competed and
traded
uh um the cost of those has gone down
dramatically uh in the 21st century so
the 21st century in that sense at least
globalization has been great because
it's delivered these very cheap products
and services but if you look at other
products and services that uh households
and consumers consume such as education
housing
uh uh healthcare and in some places
depending which country will place
uranium transportation
those have actually gone up dramatically
far far higher and faster than inflation
far higher and faster than uh wage
growth in fact if you are
in the bottom half of the social income
scale
those things have come to dominate
your income in terms of what you spend
money on so for those people
uh
it hasn't worked out so well
actually to the social contract and then
on the savers side
people as savers are you know very few
people now can afford to save for the
future and one of the things that you
see is that the growth of indebtedness
in the 21st century in the so far has
gone up for most people especially uh
middle wage and low wage uh
households and and and and people their
ability to
to save for the future has gone up
what's interesting is uh sorry it's gone
down what's interesting is it's not just
that the loves of indebtedness have gone
up but it's the fact that the people who
are indebtedness look a little bit
different they look they're younger
they're also in many cases
college educated which is different than
what you might have seen uh 25 years ago
in terms of who was indebted and what do
they kind of look like
and then finally just to uh finish the
the 21st century in the social contract
sense
also hasn't worked out very well for
uh for women uh who still earn less than
men for example and don't quite have the
opportunities as much as others as well
as for uh people of color uh it hasn't
so it's to earn a lot less employment
rates are still much lower
their participation in the economy as
any of these roles is also much less so
you get a picture that says
while the economy has grown
and capitalism has been great so far in
a social contract sense at least by
these measures we've looked at
it hasn't worked out as well for
everybody in the in the advanced
economies this is uh this is a picture
that emerges from the 23
oecd countries that we looked at and and
the united states is on the more extreme
end of most of the trends i just
described
emerging from this is a pretty complex
picture i think of the way in which the
the world is changing so you said the
you know
the united states represents sort of the
extreme
end of this um where you can see the the
largest effect size in these areas i
would assume yet yet it also seems like
there's this picture of the global east
and south
generally doing better off like people
being lifted out of poverty um
go ahead
yeah it is true so one of the uh
wonderful things about the 21st century
is in fact you know close to a billion
people have been lifted out of poverty
uh in in the in those uh roughly 20 25
years which is extraordinary but we
should be clear about where that has
happened
those
those you know billion people are mostly
in china and to some extent india so
what we say we've listed people out of
poverty we should be very specific about
mostly where that has happened there are
parts of the world that have where that
hasn't been the case uh parts of africa
parts of other parts of asia and even
parts of latin america so it's been this
lifting people out of poverty has been
very has been relatively concentrated in
china primarily and to some extent in
india
one of the things about economics and
this is something that people like bob
suller and others got nobel prize for
prizes for if you think about what is it
that drives
our economic growth
if economic growth is the way we create
economic surpluses that we can then all
enjoy and lead to prosperity right
at some level the you know the growth
desegregation models come down to two
things either you're expanding
uh labor supply
or
you are driving productivity
and the two of those when they work well
combine to give you economic gdp growth
so if you look for example at the last
50 years
both across the advanced economies but
even for the united states
the picture that you see is that much of
our economic growth has come roughly so
far at least
has come roughly in equal measure from
two things
one you know this is over the last 50 or
so years
half of it just come from expansions and
labor supply uh you can think about it
as a baby boomer generation more people
entering the workforce etc etc the other
half is roughly come from productivity
growth and the two of them have combined
to give us roughly the
economic gdp growth that we've had
now when you look forward
from where we are
we're not likely to get much lift from
the labor supply part of it partly
because most advanced economies are
aging
and so the contribution that's going to
come from expansions and labor supply
are much less i mean you can think of it
as kind of you know
a plane flying on two engines right if
one engine has been expansions the labor
supply and the others in productivity
well the labor supply engine is kind of
dying out or slowing down or you know in
its output so we're going to rely a lot
more on productivity growth and so where
does productivity growth come from well
productivity growth comes from things
like technological innovation
innovating how we do things and how we
create products and services and all of
that and technology is a big part of
that but guess what happens one of the
things that happens with
productivity growth
is that the role of technology goes up
so i come back to my example of the
factory so if you wanted a
highly productive factory it's likely
that your mix of labor inputs and
capital inputs or read that is machinery
and equipment is going to change
and that's why your factor 100 years ago
looks very different than a factory
today so but we need that kind of
technological innovation and
productivity to drive the output and
when you and then the output leads to
the output in the in the sector and
ultimately the output in the economy so
all of that is to say
you know i don't think we should stop
the technological innovation that leads
to productivity we need productivity
growth in fact going forward we're going
to need productivity growth even more
the question is
how do we make sure that even as we're
pursuing that productivity growth that
contributes to economic growth
we're also
paying attention to
how we mitigate or address the
impacts on labor and work
which is where most people derive their
livelihoods so i don't think you want to
set up a steady system of incentives
that slows down the technological
innovation and productivity growth
because
otherwise you know we're all going to be
fighting over a diminishing economic pie
i think you want to invest in that and
continue to drive that but at the same
time find ways and think about how to
address some of the
work implications of that or the impacts
on work and workers and that's been one
of the challenges that we've had i mean
we've all seen the
hollowing out if you like of the middle
class in advanced economies like america
where a big part of that is that much of
that middle class or middle income
our workers have been working in these
sectors and occupations where the impact
of
technology and productivity have
actually had a huge
impact on those jobs and those incomes
and so even though we have work in the
economy
the occupations and jobs and sectors
that are growing
have tended to be in the service sectors
invest in places like manufacturing i
mean it's a reason why
you know i i love it when you know
politicians talk about good
manufacturing jobs i mean they have a
point in the sense that historically
those have been good well-paying jobs
but
manufacturing today
is only what
eight percent of the labor force in
america right is diminished at its peak
is probably at best
close to you know the mid 40s 40 percent
as a share of the labor markets back in
the 50s right it's been going down ever
since
right and yet the service sector economy
has been growing dramatically and
many not all but many of the jobs in the
service sector economy don't pay as much
so the so so my point is you have to
think we have to think about not just
incentives but the structure of our
economy so if you look forward for
example
uh you know over the next uh you know
few decades
what are the jobs that are going to grow
as a function of both demand for that
work in the economy but also as a result
of what's less likely to be automated by
technology and ai and so forth you end
up with a list that includes care work
for example uh and and so forth and even
you know even work that we we say is
valuable which it is like teachers and
others that are harder to automate but
our labor market system
uh doesn't uh
reward and pay those occupations as much
as some of the occupations that are
declining so that those are some of what
i when i talk about the
changes in the structure of our economy
in a way that goes a little bit beyond
just local incentives is
how do we address that
how do we make sure you know as those as
those parts of our economy grow
uh which they will naturally
how do we make sure people are earning
enough to live in those as they work in
those occupations and by the way those
occupations are many of the ones that
during
you know in our current or recent
covet
moment or period here um many of where
the essential work and workers are by
the way people we've come to rely on uh
mostly in those service sector economies
that we haven't you know historically
paid well
so that that that those are real
challenges
there's that really compelling
figure that you gave at the the
beginning of our conversation where you
said uh six percent of counties account
for was it a third or two-thirds of
two-thirds two-thirds of our economic
output
um and so there's this there's this
there's this change in and dynamic
between
uh productivity and labor force
um and the productivity you're
suggesting is
what is increasing
and that is related to and contingent on
ai automation
technology is that right
well so well first of all we need
productivity to increase it's been kind
of
sluggish in the last several years in
fact it's one of the key questions that
economists worry about which is how can
we can you know how can we increase the
growth of our economic productivity it
hasn't been
performing as high you know it hasn't
been doing as well as we'd like it to do
so we'd like to actually increase it
partly because as i said
we needed more than we we've done in the
last 50 years because of the labor
supply pieces declining so we actually
would like productivity to go up even
more my expense and i just wrote a
paper recently on the hopeful
possibility that in fact we could see a
revival in productivity growth
coming out of covid but that's you know
we hope that happens uh but it's not as
short but so we need more productivity
growth uh for sure
and and the way you get productivity
growth technology and innovation is a
big part of it the other part of it is
just managerial innovation that happens
inside companies and sectors where
uh you know those companies and sectors
figure out ways to
uh organize and do what they do in
innovative but highly productive
productive ways so it's the combination
of technology and those kind of
managerial and other innovations that's
what drives
usually in a competitive context that's
what drives productivity
does that lead to us requiring less
human labor
uh it shouldn't so so
and
one of the things about uh productivity
right is
uh it's actually in some ways labor
productivity is a very simple equation
right it's it has on the numerator
value-added output
divided by
uh hours worked or labor input if you
like
so you can have a what i think of as a
virtuous version of productivity growth
versus it versus a vicious one so let me
describe the virtuous one the virtuous
one which actually leads to job growth
is when in fact
you expand the numerators in other words
there's innovations use of technology uh
in the ways that i talked about before
that leads to companies and sectors
creating more valuable output
uh more of it and more valuable output
so you expand the numerator so if you do
that and you expand the numerator much
higher and faster then you're
reducing the denominator which is the
labor hours worked you end up with a
virtuous cycle in the sense that the
economy grows productivity grows
everything expands the demand for work
actually goes up and that's a virtuous
cycle and the last time we saw a great
version of that was actually in the late
90s
this is if you recall before that uh bob
solid kind of framed the
um
uh what he calls what ended up being
called the solo paradox which is this
idea that you know before the mid and
late 90s you saw computers everywhere
except in the productivity figures right
and that's because we hadn't seen the
kinds of deployment of technology the
managerial innovations
do the kind of
what i call the numerator driven
productivity growth which which when it
did happen in the mid to late 90s you
created this virtuous cycle now let me
describe the vicious cycle which is the
if you like the not so great version of
productivity growth is when
you don't expand the numerator but what
you do is simply reduce the denominator
so in other words you reduce the hours
worked
in other words you become very efficient
at delivering the same output or maybe
even less of the output so you reduce
the denominator
that can lead to productivity but it's
of the vicious kind right because you're
not expanding the output it's simply
reducing the inputs of the labor inputs
therefore you end up with less
employment uh fewer jobs and that's not
great and that that's when you get what
you asked about which is where you need
less labor and that's the vicious
version of productivity you don't want
that either i see so how does
how does the reality of ai and
automation
replacing human labor and human work
essentially increasingly completely over
time
uh factor into and affect the virtuous
and vicious
versions of productivity
well well first of all
we shouldn't assume that ai is
simply going to replace
work i think uh
you know we should think about this in
this context of what you might call
complements and substitutes so if if if
our ai technology is
deployed in ways that are primarily
about uh and both developed and then
deployed in a way that is entirely
substitutive of work
then you could have work decline but
there's also other ways to deploy ai
technology where it's complementary and
complements work
uh uh and and in that case you know we
shouldn't have to think about as much
about uh losing jobs so let me let me
give you some
specifics on this so
uh
we've done research and others have too
but let me describe at least what we've
done but i think the general consensus
is emerging that is close to what at
least we found in our research which is
that so we looked at um you know so the
bureau of labor statistics kind of
tracks uh in the u.s tracks roughly 800
plus occupations
uh we looked at all those occupations in
the economy we also looked at the actual
particular tasks and activities that
people actually do this is because
any of our jobs and occupations are not
monolithic right they're in a
uh you know they're made up of several
different tasks right i spent part of my
day
typing or talking to people or analyzing
things so that we were all an amalgam of
different tasks so and we looked at over
2000 tasks that go into these different
occupations but let me let me get to
where we ended up so we ended up was we
you know we looked at
what current and expected ai technology
and alteration technologies can do and
we came to the conclusion that at least
you know over the next couple decades
at the task level and i emphasize the
task level not the job level these are
tasks i'll come back to jobs at the task
level
these technologies look like they could
automate as much as 50 percent of the
tasks and activities that people do and
it's important again emphasize those are
tasks not jobs now when you
take those
highly automatable tasks back and map
them to to the occupations in the
economy what we concluded was that
something like at most
10 percent of the occupations
look like they have
all of their constituent tasks
automatable
right
that that's a very important
uh thing to note right ten percent of
what the occupations look like they have
yeah close to 100 of their tasks that
are automatable in what time
uh this is over the next couple decades
okay is that like two decades or
uh we looked at this over two decades
two decades okay right now right we're
scenarios around that because it's very
hard to be precise because you know you
can imagine the rate of technology
development speeding up i'll come back
to that but right but the point is
you know it's only
you know 10 of the in our analysis
anyway 10 of the occupations look like
they have all of their constituent tasks
that are automatable in that rough time
frame but at the same time what we also
found is that
you know something like 60 of the
occupations
have something like a third
of their constituent tasks that are
automatable in that same period well
what does that what does that mean what
that actually means is that many more
jobs and occupations are going to change
than get fully automated away because
what happens is sure you know you know
some activity that i used to do myself
now you know if you know that activity
can be done in an automated fashion but
i still do other things too right so
this effect of kind of the jobs that
will change is actually a bigger effect
than the jobs that will disappear
completely now that's not to say there
won't be any occupations that will
decline in fact what we found in our
research and we ended up kind of titling
the report
research report jobs
lost and jobs gained we probably should
have fully titled the jobs lost jobs
gained and jobs changed because all
three phenomena will happen
right
yes there'll be occupations that will
decline but there'll also be occupations
that will grow actually
and then there'll be lots more
occupations that will change so i think
we need to take the full
picture into account it's a bit like
i guess a good example of the jobs
change portion is
uh a good historical example of this is
um
uh the the one of the bank teller right
which is
if you look if you looked at what a bank
teller did in 1968
uh versus what the bank teller does now
it's very very different right the bank
teller back then
spent all their time counting money
either to take it from you to give it
back to you right when you went up to
the bank teller or the advent of atm
machines or the atm machine automated
much of that so we still have bank
tellers today but they don't you know
the majority of the time isn't spent
doing that right they may do that on an
exception basis but their jobs have
changed dramatically
right but there's still an occupation
called a bank teller and in fact until
about i think the precise date is
something like 2006 i think
uh you know what we actually had was
bank the number of bank tellers in the
u.s economy had actually grown since the
early 70s to about 2006 and that's
because
you know we actually oh the demand for
bank tellers went up not on a per bank
basis
but on a economy-wide basis because we
ended up opening up so many more branch
banks in 2000 you know by 2006 that we
had in 1968. so the collective demand
for
banking
actually drove the growth in the number
of bank tellers even though the
number of bank tellers per branch might
have gone down so that's an example of
where you know a growing economy can
create its own demand for work back to
this virtuous uh cycle that i was
talking about as opposed to the vicious
cycle that i was talking about so this
phenomenon of jobs changing is is an
important one that often gets lost
uh in the
conversation about technology and
automation and jobs and so
to come back to your original question
about
you know substitutes we shouldn't just
think of
technology substituting for jobs is the
only thing that happens but also that
technology can complement
uh work and jobs in fact one of the one
of the things to think about is you know
particularly for
ai researchers or ai people who develop
these automation technologies i think
on the one hand while it's actually
certainly useful
uh to think of human benchmarks when we
say you know how we built machines and
systems that match human vision or human
dexterity and so forth that's a useful
way to set goals and targets
for technology development and ai
development but in an economic sense
it's actually less useful because it's
less likely to to lead to technologies
that are more
substitutes because we've built them to
match what humans can do imagine if we
said
you know let's build technology machines
that can see around corners or do the
kinds of things that humans can't do
then we're more likely in that case to
build
more complementing technologies and
substituted technologies i think that's
one of the things that we should be
thinking about and doing a heck of a lot
more
to achieve
this is very interesting so you can
think of every job as basically a list
of tasks
and
ai technology can automate say some
number of tasks per job
but then the job changes in a sense that
either you can spend more time on the
tasks that remain and increase
productivity by just focusing on those
tasks or the fact that ai technology is
being integrated into the job process
will create a few new tasks um the
tension i see though is that we're
headed towards uh a generality
with ai where
we want
we're moving towards all tasks being
automated
um so
perhaps over shorter time scales it
seems like
we'll be able to spend more time on
fewer tasks or our jobs will change
in order to
meet and
work on the new tasks that ai technology
demands of us but
you know generality is a movement
towards the
end of human level problem solving on
work and objective related tasks
so so it seems like it would be
increasingly shrinking is is that a view
that you you share does that make sense
uh well the question your your
observation makes sense i don't know if
i fully share it um but just to back up
the step um
yeah so so if you ask me over the next
um
few decades i mean our researchers
looked at the next couple of decades
yeah if you generalize something because
others have looked at this too by the
way and come up with
you know obviously slightly different
numbers and views but but i think
they're generally in the same direction
that i just described so if you say over
the next couple decades what do i worry
about i certainly don't worry about the
disappearance of work
uh for sure uh but that doesn't mean
that all is well right i still there's
still things that i worry about so i
still worry about
uh sure you know while we're gonna have
work because i think you know what we
found for example is the net of
jobs lost and jobs gained and jobs
changed the net of all of that in in the
in the economies that we've looked at is
still a net
positive in the sense that there's more
work
uh gained net than lost now
that doesn't mean we should all then be
less rest on our laurels and be happy
that hey
we're not facing a jobless future so i
think we still have a few other
challenges to deal with i want to come
back to your future future agi question
in a second so what are the things to
worry about even in this
you know stage where i say don't worry
about the disappearance of work well
there's still a few more things to worry
about i think you want to worry about
uh the you know the transitions all
right the skill transition so if some
jobs are declining and some jobs are
growing and some jobs are changing
all of that is going to create a big
requirement for skilling and re-skilling
either to help people
get into these new jobs that are growing
or if their jobs are changing gain the
new skills that work well alongside what
the machine the tasks of the machines
can do so all of that says reskilling is
a really big deal which is why you know
everybody's talking about reskilling now
though i don't think we're doing it fast
enough for it scale enough
uh at the scale and pace that we should
be doing it but that's one thing to
worry about
the other thing to worry about are the
effects on wages so even when you have
enough work if you look at the pattern
of the
the jobs gained most of them not all of
them but most many of them
many of them are actually
jobs that pay less at least in our
current labor market structure right so
care work is you know hard to fully
automate because it turns out that hey
it's actually harder to automate
somebody doing physical mechanical tasks
than say somebody doing uh you know
analytical work uh and but it turns out
the person doing analytical work where
you can probably automate what they do a
lot easier also happens with the person
who's
earning a little bit more than the
person doing the physical mechanical
tasks but by the way that person is one
that we don't pay much in the first
place so you end up with
you know physical mechanical activities
that are hard to automate also growing
and being demanded but then we don't pay
much for them so the wage effects are
something to worry about
and even in the example i gave you of
complementing work
that's great from the point of view of
people and machines working alongside
each other but even that has interesting
wage effects too right because at one
end which i'll call the happy end and
i'll come back to the challenge the end
the happy end is when you know we
automate some of what you do uh lucas
and
the the combination of uh what the
machine now does for you and what you
you still do yourself as a human
both are highly valuable so the combo is
even more productive and this is the
example that's often given with the
classic story of uh radiologists right
so machines can you know maybe read some
of those images way better than the
radiologist but there are that's not all
the radiologist does there's other
there's a whole other value-added
activities and tasks that the
radiologist does that the machine
reading
that's understanding the mri doesn't do
but now you've got a radiologist
partnered up with a machine the
combination's great so that's a happy
example probably the productivity goes
up the wages of that radiologist go up
that's a happy story let me describe the
less happy end of that complementing uh
story the less happy end of that is when
the machine automates a portion of your
work but the portion that it automates
is actually the value-added portion of
that work and what's left over is even
more commoditized
uh
commoditized in the sense that many many
many more people can do it
and therefore the skill requirements for
that actually go down as opposed to go
up because the hard part of what you
used to do is not being done by a
machine
the danger with that is that that then
potentially depresses the wages for that
work even the way you're complementing
so even the complimenting story i
described earlier
isn't always in one direction from a
wage effect uh and its impact so all of
that to step back is to say the second
thing to worry if the first thing is
reskilling the second thing to worry
about are these wage effects
and then the final thing to worry about
are how we think about
redesigning work itself and the
workflows themselves so
all of that is to say even in a world
where we have enough work as in the next
few decades we're still not gonna have
to work these issues now
you were posing a question about what
about in the long long futures i
actually think it's in the long future
that we're going to have
agi
uh i i'm not one who thinks it's as
imminent as perhaps others think do you
have a timeline you'd be willing to
share
no i don't have a timeline i just think
that there are many many hard problems
that we we still seem like a long way
from now the reason i don't have a
timeline is that hey we could have a
breakthrough happen
in the next decade that changes the
timeline so we haven't figured out how
to do causal reasoning we haven't
figured out how to do what uh you know
kahneman called system two uh activities
we've solved system one tasks but we
have systems so there's a whole bunch of
things that you know we haven't solved
issues of uh you know uh you know how we
do high higher level cognition or
meta-level cognition we haven't solved
through you know how we how we do meta
learning transfer learning so there's a
whole bunch of things
that we haven't quite solved now we're
making progress on some of those things
i mean some of the things that have
happened with these
large language universal models is
really breathtaking right but i think
that the the color in my view at least
the collection of things that we have to
solve before we get to agi
there's too many that still feel
unsolved to me now
we could have somebody break through in
a day that's why i'm not ready to give a
prediction in terms of timeline but
these seem like really hard problems to
me
and
many of my friends who are working on
some of these issues also seem to think
these are hard problems although there
are some of them who think that you know
we're almost there that all we need to
you know deep learning will get us to
most places we need to get to
uh and reinforcement learning will get
us most of what we need all right so
those are my friends who think that
think that it's more imminent decade or
two away sometimes they say
yeah some of them said decade or two uh
so you know there's there's a
there's a lot of real debate about this
in fact you may have seen one of the
things that um was i participated in uh
you know a couple years ago was and
martin ford uh put together a book
collection a book that was a collection
of interviews with a bunch of people
this is is this book architecture of
intelligence and you had a you know a
wonderful range of people in that book i
was fortunate enough to be included but
you know there many more people are way
more interesting than me people like you
know demonstrabis and joshua banjo and a
whole bunch of people it's really
terrific collection
and one of the things that he asked that
group in who are in that book was to
ask them to give a view
as to when they think agi would be
achieved and what came out of it is a
very wide range from you know 2029 and i
think that was ray kurzweil uh who stuck
to his date uh and all the way to
something like 500 years from now so and
that's a group of you know people who
are deep in the field right and you get
that very wide range so i think
for me i'm much more interested in the
in the real things that we're gonna need
to break through and i don't know when
we'll make those breakthroughs it could
be imminent it could be a long time from
now but there just seemed to be to be
some really hard problems to solve
but but if but if you take the view
right let's so to to follow your thought
if you take the view you know the
thought experiment to say okay let's
just assume we truly achieve agi
uh uh in all its sense in you know in
both in the
you know aj and the you know some people
say in the oracula i mean it depends
what form of the agi takes if the agi
takes the form of both
you know the you know the cognitive part
of that
coupled with the embodiment of that of
physical machines that can physically
put you know participate and you truly
have
you know
uh agi in a fully embodied sense as well
as a in a digital cognitive sense
uh what happens to humans and work in
that in that case
uh i don't know i think that's where
presumably
those machines allow us to create
enormous surpluses and bounties uh in in
an economic sense so presumably we can
afford to pay everybody uh you know to
give everybody money and resources and
so then the question is in a world of
true abundance because presumably
they'll help us solve these you know
these machines agrs will help us solve
those things and while the true
abundance
what do people do in that
right i guess it's kind of a kin as
somebody said to you know a star trek
economy what do you know what do people
do in a star trek economy when they can
replicate and do everything right i
don't know i guess we explore the
universe we
we do creative things i don't know i'm
sure we'll find some we'll create some
economic system
uh that takes advantage of the things
that people can still uniquely do
even though they're although i probably
have a very different
economic value and purpose i think
humans will always find a way to create
either literally or quasi-economic
systems of some of exchange of something
or other
so if we focus here on the next few
decades where
automation is increasingly taking over
particular tasks and jobs
what is it
that we can do to ensure
positive outcomes for
those that are beginning to be left
behind by the economy that require skill
training
and
those whose jobs are
soon to have many of the tasks automated
starting now actually in the next decade
or two i think there are several things
as there's actually a pretty robust list
of things we need to do actually uh to
tackle this issue i think one is just
re-skilling
uh
we know that there's already shortage of
skills we know you know even before we
think about
you know you know we we've had skill
mismatches for quite a while before any
of this fully kicks in so this is a
challenge we've had for a while so this
quest of reskilling is is a is a massive
undertaking and here the questions
really paid doing it at pace and scale
because while there are quite a quite a
lot of you know
re-skilling examples one can come across
uh and there are many of them that have
been very successful but i think the key
thing to note about many of them not all
of them but many of them
is that they tend to be small
uh right so one of my uh you know one of
the questions one should always ask
about all the great re-skilling examples
we hear of is how big is it
right how many people went through that
program and i think you'll find that
many of them not all of them many of
them are relatively score at least small
relative to the scale of the reskilling
that we need to do
now there have been a few big ones um
you know i happen to like for example
you know walmart has had these walmart
academies uh it's been written about
publicly quite a bit but what's
interesting about that is it's one of
the few
really large-scale re-skilling
retraining programs uh through their
academies getting them something like i
can't remember for reading this but
something like they've put uh something
like 800 000 people through those uh
academies
i like that example simply because the
numbers start to sound big and
meaningful now you know i don't know i
haven't evaluated the programs but are
they good but i think the scale is about
right right we so so the reskilling at
scale is going to be really important
number one the other thing we're going
to need to think about is
you know how do we address the wage
question now the wage question is
important
you know for lots of reasons here one is
if you remember early in our
conversation we talked about the fact
that over the last two decades
for many people wages haven't gone up uh
there have been relative wages
stagnation this relative compared to you
know rates of inflation or the cost of
living and how things have gone up uh
wages haven't gone up so the waste
technician is one we already have before
we think about technology but then as
we've just discussed technology may even
exacerbate that even when there are jobs
and the changing continuing changing
structure of our economy
will also exacerbate that so what do we
do about the wage question so one could
consider you know raising minimum wage
right one could consider
ideas like ubi i mean you know we can
come back and talk about ubi
i kind of have mixed views about ubi
what i like about it is the fact that
it's at least a recognition
that we have a wage problem that people
don't earn enough to live
right so i like it in that sense
now the complication with it in my view
is that you know well of course you know
one of the primary things that work does
for you uh for the vast majority of
people
it's that's how they
they derive their livelihood their
income so it's important uh but work
also does other things right it's a way
to socialize as a way to give purpose
and meaning etc so i think you behind
you know what it may solve the income
part of that which is an important part
of that you may not address the other
pieces of the other things that work
does so but we have to solve the wage
problem i think we also have to solve
this uh geographic concentration problem
you know we did some work where you know
we looked at
um uh all the counties in america right
so at the time that we did this because
the the the definition of what's
accounted in america kind of changes a
little bit year from year but at the
time that we did this work which was
back in 2019 though i think we looked at
something like
3149 counties across america
and what we're looking at there was a it
was a range of factors about you know
economic investment uh you know economic
vibrancy
uh jobs wage growth we looked at like 40
different variables in each county but
i'm just going to focus on one which is
uh job growth
so when we looked at job growth in the
across those counties
while at the national level we're all
celebrating the job growth that had
happened
uh
you know coming out the 2008 recession
you know uh and over the last you know
between 2008 and
2018 was the data set we looked at
uh first of all it was at the national
level was great but when you looked at
it at the county level what you suddenly
found is that you know a lot of that job
growth was concentrated in places where
roughly a third of the of the nation's
workers live
the other two thirds of the place where
people live either saw
flat or no job growth
or even continued job decline
so all of that is to say
you know we also have to solve this
question of how do we get more even job
growth and wage growth across the
country
uh within the united states we've also
done similar work we've looked at these
micro regions in europe
and you see similar patterns although
maybe not quite as extreme as the us but
you see similar patterns where
some places get a lot of the job and
wage growth and some places get less of
it
it's just a function of the structure of
our economy so we'd have to solve that
too
uh this is the
and then the other thing we need to
solve is the is the classic case of the
hollowing out of the middle class
because what the if you look at the the
the pattern of you know mostly driven by
technology to some extent the
a lot of the job declines or the job
jobs lost as a result of technology have
primarily been in the middle wage middle
class jobs
and a lot of the job growth has been in
the lower wage jobs so this question of
the hollowing out of the middle class is
actually a really particular problem
which has all kinds of social political
implications by the way
but that's the other thing to to to to
figure out so
let me stop there but i think these are
some of the things we're going to need
to tackle uh in the in the near term and
this is mostly i've made that list most
in the context of say an economy like
the
like the united states i think if you go
outside of the united states and you
know outside of the
the advanced economies
uh
you know there's a there's a different
set of challenges so
uh i'm talking about places outside of
uh you know the oecd countries and china
so you go to places like india
big lots of parts of africa and latin
america where you've got a very
different problem which is
those are very young demographic
demographically young populations
china isn't but india and most of africa
is and parts of latin america are and so
they're the challenges
you know a huge number of people are
entering the workforce
so the challenge there is how do you
create work for them uh and that's a
that's a huge challenge right so when
you look at those places the challenge
is just how do you create enough jobs uh
in very demographically young countries
and the pictures now gotten a little bit
more complicated
in recent years than perhaps in the past
because in the past the the story was if
you were a developing country a poor
developing country
your path to prosperity was
to
join the global economy uh be part of
you know either the labor supply or the
cheap labor supply often and go from
being an agrarian country to an
industrialized country and then
ultimately maybe someday you'll become a
service economy which most advanced
economies are
so that path of industrialization
is less assured today than it used to be
for a bunch of reasons some of those
reasons have to do with the fact that
advanced economies now no longer seek uh
cheap labor abroad as much as they used
to
right they still do for some sectors but
not less so for many other sectors i
mean uh right so so we're less likely to
do that part of that is technology the
fact that
in some ways manufacturing has changed
we can now going forward do things more
like 3d printing and so forth so this
idea of you know the industrialization
path is less available
to poor countries than it used to be in
fact economists like danny rodrick have
written about this and called it this
kind of
premature de-industrialization
challenge which is facing many
low-income countries so so we have to
think about what is the path for those
countries and by the way these are
countries if you think about it from the
point of view of
technology and ai in particular
uh you know the the ai technological
competition globally is rapidly seen
rapidly seems to have come down to be a
race between the u.s led by the us but
increasingly by china
and others are largely being left behind
in right and that includes in some cases
parts of europe but for sure parts of
the poor poor developed developing
economies so the question is
you know you know in a world in a in a
in a future in which
technology is developing
and the uh capacity for technology is
developing
in a you know in a in a in a you know at
different paces dramatically different
paces for different countries
and the nature of globalization itself
is changing
what is the path for these poor
uh developing countries i think that's a
very tough question that we don't have
very many good answers for by the way
but me
but we i just mean people will think
about developing economies and
developing economies themselves i think
that's one of the tough challenges i
think for the
next several decades of the 21st century
i think that does a really good job of
explaining the
you know some of these really
significant problems i i'm curious what
the most significant findings of your
own personal work
or the work more broadly being done at
mckinsey are with regards to these
problems and issues i really appreciate
some of the the figures that you're able
to share so if you have any more of
those they're really helpful i think for
painting a
a picture of where things are at and
where they're moving
well i think the only the question on
these kind of left behind
countries and economies as i said you
know these are topics we're trying to
research and understand i don't think we
have uh you know
any kind of pad simple
solutions to them
uh we do know though uh that in fact one
of the some of the things if you look at
the pattern so we a lot of our work is
very empirical right we're typically
looking at what has happened what is
actually happening on the ground one of
the things that you do see for
developing economies is that
the developing economies that are
part of a regional ecosystem
either because of their value chains and
supply chains so take the case of
a a country like vietnam right uh you
know it's it's kind of in the
value chain ecosystem around china for
example so it benefits from being a
participant or an input uh into the
chinese value chain so when when you
have countries and you could argue
that's what's happened with construct
mexico and a few others so there's
something about being a participant in
the value chains or supply chains of
these that are emerging somewhat
regionally actually
so that seems to be at least one path
the other path that we've seen is that
when you've got
developing countries that tend to have
you know
large and competitive private sectors uh
and emphasize competitive that actually
seems to make a difference so we we did
some empirical work where we looked at
the
you know something like 75 developing
countries over the last um
25 years to see
you know what are some of the patterns
of which ones of those have done well
does the growth and development and and
so forth and what some of the factors
that you see we found in that research
is in fact when when when when the
countries that happen to have as i said
one is proximity to either or
participants in the global value chains
of
other large uh
ecosystems or economies did well
second those that seem to have these
large and vibrant and very competitive
private sector economies
also seem to to to do better and then
also those that had uh you know
unquestionably obviously uh you know
resource endowments uh did well so that
i don't know oil and you know natural
resources and those kinds of things uh
also seem to do well and then we also
find that those that seem to have more
uh mixed economies so they didn't just
rely on one part of their economy but
they had uh two or three different kinds
of activities going on in their economy
then maybe a little bit of a
manufacturing sector a little bit of a
cultural sector a little bit of a of a
service sector so the ones that had more
mixed economies seemed to do well and
then the other big thing was the ones
that seem to be reforming their
economies um uh seem to do well so at
least those are some patterns i don't
think those are
guaranteed uh in any of them uh to be
the recipe for the next few decades
probably because much of that picture
around global supply chains is changing
and much of the role of technology and
how it affects uh how people participate
in the global economy is changing so
i think those are useful but i don't
know if they're in a short recipe going
forward there's certainly been have been
the patents for the last 25 years
but maybe that's the place to start if
you look forward to pivot a bit here
um
i'm curious if you could explain what
you see as the
central forces that are currently acting
on the global economy
well i'll tell you some of the things
that are interesting that we find
interesting
one is in fact the fact that you know
more more and more and more the role of
technology in the global economy is
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
right in the sense that technology seems
to be found become you know way more
general purpose in the sense that it's
foundational to every company every
sector and every country so
and and so the role of that is is
interesting and it also has these other
uh outsized effects because we know that
uh technology often lead to the
phenomenon of
superstar firms and superstar returns
and and so forth so you see you see that
quite a bit uh so the role of technology
is an important one
the the other one that's going on is the
is what's happening with uh
globalization itself right because you
know and by globalization i i just mean
the the
the movement of value and activity
related to the global economy so we did
some work a few years ago that we
we've tried to update regularly where we
looked at all the things of economic
value so we looked at for example you
know the flow of products and goods
across the world the the flow of money
uh finances and other financing and
other things the flow of services the
the movement of people uh and even the
movement of data uh and kind of you know
uh data related activities what was
interesting is that one of the things
that has changed is that the
the the globalization in the form of the
flow of goods and services it actually
kind of slowed down actually and so
you know that's why one of the reasons
people were questioning is you know is
globalization dead does it slow down
well that certainly looks that way if
you're looking at it through the lens of
the flow of
products and goods
but not the case if you're looking
necessarily the flow of money for
example not necessarily if you're
looking at the flow of people and for
sure
not the case if you look at the flow of
data around the world one of the things
that's i think underappreciated is just
how digitized the global economy has
become
and just the massive amounts of data
flows
digital data flows that now happen
across borders between countries
and how much that is tied into the way
the globalization economy the globalized
globalization works so if you're looking
globalization through the lens of
digitization digital data flows
nothing is slowed down in fact if
anything it's accelerated actually uh
that's why you often you will hear
people were looking at it through that
lens say oh no you know
it's even more globalized than ever
before but people looking at it through
the flow of products and goods for
example might say oh it seems looks like
it just slowed down so that's one of the
things that's that's changing and it's
also the the globalization of digital
data flows is actually interesting
because one of the things that it does
is it changed the participation map
quite significantly so we did some work
where if you look at through that lens
you suddenly found that you have
many more countries participating and
many more
kinds of companies participating as
opposed to just a few countries and a
few companies participate in the global
economy you have much more diversity of
participation so you have
you know very tiny companies a two
three two three person company in in
some country plugged into the global
economy using digital technology and
digital platforms in ways that wouldn't
have happened before if you're a two
three person company uh 30 years ago
right so so
that that's been so this digitization of
the global economies is really quite
quite fascinating the other thing that's
going on in the global economy is the
you know is the is obviously the
the rebalancing if you like uh where you
know with the emergence of china is a
big economy in its own right
that is changing the the gravitational
structure if you like uh of the global
economy in some in some very profound
ways right um
uh where you know
in ways that we haven't quite
had before because
sure in the past you've had other large
economies like germany and japan and
others right as as as large you can't
but none of them were ever as big as the
united states
and also
all of them whether it's japan or
germany or any of the european countries
largely operated in a framework uh a
globalization of a global framework
that was largely kind of western-centric
in a way but now you have this very
large economy that's very different it's
very very large uh will be the in you
know the second largest economy in the
world that is quite different
uh but yet is you know tied into the so
that that gravitational structural shift
is is is very very it's very very
important uh then of course the other
thing that's happening is you know
what's happening with
uh supply chains and global value chains
and that's interesting partly because
you know we're so intertwined with how
supply chains and value chains work
but at the same time it changes how we
think about the resilience of economies
and we've just seen that during this
covert last year
where you know all of a sudden
uh we're quite everything concerned
about you know the resilience of our
supply chains with respect to you know
essential products and services like
medical supplies and so forth so i think
people are now starting to rethink about
how do we think about the structure of
the global economy in terms of uh you
know these value chains
and you know and and then there's you
know and
we should have at some point also
mentioned other kinds of technologies
that are happening so because it's not
all
ai and digital technologies as much as
uh i love that and spent a lot of time
on that i think you know other
technological developments that are
interesting include what's happening in
the in in biosciences or the life
sciences and we've just seen kind of
spectacular demonstrations of that with
these you know the mrna vaccines that
you know were rapidly developed but i
think a lot more has been happening with
just
amazing progress that we still
at the very early stages of with regards
to the you know biotechnology uh and the
life sciences i think we're going to see
even more profound uh societally and
profound impacts from those developments
in the coming decades so so these are
some of the things uh that um
that that
i see happening the global economy
now of course climate change looms large
over all of this is a thing that could
really
impact things in quite dramatic and
quite
existentially concerning ways
so
in terms of this global economy
can you explain what the
economic center of gravity is where it's
been and where it's going
uh well undoubtedly the economic center
of gravity has been the united states if
you look at the last 50 years right it's
been the largest economy on the planet
uh
largest in every sense right either is a
is a
as a as a market to sell into uh as a
kind of its own market uh everybody
around the world for the last 50 years
been thinking about how do we access and
sell into pro you know consumers and
buyers in the united states it's been
the largest market it's also been the
largest uh you know uh uh
you know developer and deployer of
technologies and innovation so so in all
of those ways it's been the united
states as the big kind of gravitational
pull
but i think going forward uh that's
going to shift because you know at
current cost and speed
the chinese economy will be
as large
uh and you now start to have even other
economies becoming large too like in
like india so i think
you know the the i think the the some
you know economic historians who created
a wonderful map where they showed the
movement of the gravitational center the
global economy i think they went back a
thousand years
and while it's been in the western
hemisphere primarily the united states i
think somewhere in the mid-atlantic it's
been kind of been shifting east
uh a little bit most because the chinese
economy primarily but also india and
others come to grow so that's
that that's clearly one of the big
changes going on in the global economy
so the its structure and its center of
gravity and with this increase of
globalization
how do you see ai is fitting into and
affecting globalization
you know the impact on globalization
i i i don't think that's the that's the
way i would think about the impact of
air of course it'll affect globalization
because anytime you anything to do with
products goods and services um and
because ai is going to affect all of
those things so to the extent that those
things are playing out on the global
economy landscape they'll be you know ai
will affect those things i think the the
impact of ai quite in at least in my
mind is person primarily about
any economy uh
whether it's the global economy or a
national economy or a company right so i
think it's
it's how it's profoundly going to change
many things about how any economic
entity works right because we know it'll
affect
uh the you know capital labor inputs we
know
it'll affect productivity uh and you
know and we know it'll change the rates
of innovation because imagine the kind
because you know while we you know in
this conversation at least we we talked
i think mostly about
air's impact on
uh on labor markets we should not forget
air's impact on innovation on
productivity on the kinds of creation of
products goods and services that we
can't imagine and how hopefully it's
going to accelerate
those developments i mean you know look
at you know what you know deepmind did
with alpha fold right which is cracking
a 50-year problem that's going to lead
to all kinds of
hopefully you know biomedical uh you
know innovations and other things so i
think
one the big impact is going to be how ai
affects innovation uh and ultimately
productivity and the kinds of things
we're going to see whether it's products
goods and services that we're going to
see in the economy and so of course any
economy
that takes advantage of that and
embraces those innovations will
obviously see the benefit to the growth
of their economy and of course if on a
global scale on a global stage in the
global economy we have some countries
do that more than others then of course
it will affect who gets ahead who's more
competitive
and who potentially gets left behind so
one of the other things we've looked at
is you know
you know what is the rate of ai
participation whether in terms of
developments or contributing to
developments or just simply deploying
technologies or having the capacity to
play technologies or having the
talent and people who can either both
contribute to the to the deployment or
the development and also embrace it in
companies and sectors and you see a
picture that's very
different around the world again you see
the us and china we're ahead of
everybody and you see some countries in
europe and even europe is not uniform
right some countries in uniform in some
countries in europe doing more of that
than others
and then a whole bunch of others who are
being left behind so again
ai will impact the global economy in
this sense of how it impacts each of the
economies that participate and each of
the companies that participate in the
global economy in their products and
services and their innovations and
outputs
so i wouldn't know now on the you know
on the you know there are other things
that will play out on the global stage
related to ai but you know from an
economy standpoint i think i'd see it
through the lens of
the participating companies and
countries and economies and how that
then plays out on the global stage so so
there's there's also this facet of how
this technological innovation and
development for example with ai and also
technologies which may contribute to and
mitigate climate change all affect
global catastrophic and existential risk
so i'm i'm curious how you see
global catastrophic and existential
risks as potentially fitting into
this
evolution of the the global economy of
of labor
and society as we move forward
um
well i think it depends whether you're
asking whether ai itself represents a
catastrophic or existential risk uh you
know many people have written about this
but i think that question is tied up
with the you know the view on how do we
think about
uh you know how close we are to ai or
how close we are so to agi and how close
we are to uh you know uh you know uh you
know
uh
superhuman uh uh ai capabilities um
uh and so and i think we're not
in as we discussed earlier i don't think
we're close yet but there are other
things to think about
even as as we
progress in that direction these include
uh some of the safety considerations uh
the control considerations uh and how we
make sure we're deploying and using ai
uh uh safely we know that you know
uh there's you know particular problems
with regards to things like even with
narrow ais it's sometimes called how do
we think about kind of
rewarding goal corruption uh for example
how do we think about
you know the kind of you know how we
avoid the kind of interference uh you
know catastrophic interference between
say tasks and goals
uh how do we think about that how we so
so they're all these kind of safety
related things even
on our way to agi
um
that we still need to think about so in
that sense these are things to worry
about i also think you know we should be
thinking about questions of
you know value and goal alignment and
these also get very complicated for a
whole bunch of both philosophical
reasons but also quite practical reasons
and that's why i love the work for
example that stuart russell has been
doing on how we think about human
compatible ai and how do we build these
kind of the kind of value alignment and
goal alignment
that we should be thinking about so
these are
even you know even on our way to agi
both the safety control and these kind
of
value alignment and somewhat normative
questions about how we think about
normativity and you know what what what
does it even mean right to think about
normative things in the case of value
alignment with the ai these are
important things now
that's if you're thinking about
catastrophic at least or at least
existential risk with regards to ai even
way before you get to
uh agi then then you you have the kinds
of things that you know at that point
uh that nick bostrom and others have
worried about i think you know we should
you know we should
you know because those are non-zero
probability concerns
uh we should invest uh you know
uh all you know effort into working on
those uh existential
potential catastrophic problems
uh but uh you know i'm not super worried
about those anytime soon uh but that
doesn't mean we should invest and work
on those kind of the kinds of concerns
that
um uh that nick and others write about
but there are also questions about uh to
think about about ai governance uh in
the sense of
you know
governance in the sense of we're gonna
have many participating entities here
we're gonna have the the companies that
are leading the development of these
technologies we're going to have
governments that are going to want to
participate and use and deploy these
technologies
we're going to have issues around you
know
you know when to deploy these
technologies
use and misuse
uh you know we also have
uh you know and many of these questions
become particularly important when you
think about
uh the deployment of ai
especially in particular arenas uh you
know so imagine if once we have ai or
agi that's capable of
uh you know manipulation for example or
persuasion
or
those kinds of things or capabilities
that allow us to detect lies or be able
to do you know interfere or play with
signals intelligence or even
cryptography and number theory i mean uh
uh crypto cryptographic systems um
rely on a lot of kind of things in prime
number theory for example or and then or
if we think about arenas like autonomous
weapons so once you talk about aai or
agi that's capable of doing these kinds
of things
questions of governance become
ever more important i mean they're
really important now when we think about
how ai may not be used for things like
deep fakes and disinformation but is the
sooner the closer we get to the kinds of
areas that i was describing here it
becomes even more important to think
about governance and
what's permissible to deploy where and
how and how do we do that in a
transparent way and how do we deal with
the challenges of the ai about you know
attribution for example one of the one
of the one of the one of the nice things
about
other you know potentially
uh risky technologies or developments
like i don't know
nuclear science or
chemical weapons and so forth at least
those things
they're easy to detect when they happen
uh and there's always you know it's
relatively it's relatively it's
relatively easy to do attribution and
that you know verify that it happened
and was used it's much harder with the
ai systems so these questions of
governance and
and so forth become monumentally
important so those are some of the
things we should think about
how do you see the way in which the
climate change crisis arose given
human systems and human civilization so
what is it about human civilizations and
human systems that has led to the
climate change crisis and how do we not
allow our systems to function and fail
in the same way with regards to
ai and powerful technologies in the 21st
century
well i i'm not i'm not an expert on
climate science by the way so i i
shouldn't speculate just how we got to
where we are but i think the way we've
used certain technologies and fossil
fuels i think is a big part of that the
way our economies have relied on that is
our only mode of
you know energy and uh is is is part of
that and the fact that we've done that
in a relatively
costless way in terms of pricing the
effects on our environment and our
climate i think is a big part of it so
and the fact that we haven't had very
many as effective and as efficient
alternatives historically i think is a
big part of that so i think all of that
is part of
how we how we how we got here in some
ways but i think others more expert than
me should can talk about that i think if
i think about ai i think one of the
things that um
you know is is potentially
challenging about ai
if in fact we think there's a chance
that we'll get to these
you know superhuman capabilities and agi
is that
you know we may not have the opportunity
to iterate our way there right i think
quite often with a lot of these uh
deployment technologies i think
you know a a practical thing that has
served us well in the past has been this
idea that you know well
let's try a few experiments
we'll fix it if it fails or if it
doesn't work and we'll iterate and do
better and kind of iterate our way to
the right answer well if we believe that
we can there is a real possibility of
achieving
agi
we may not have that opportunity to
iterate in that same way
right uh and so that's one of the things
that's potentially
different perhaps
um
because if we do get you know we can't
undo that as it were
if you truly get to you know agi so i
think
think about these existential things so
maybe in that sense there's a
there's a maybe there's something of a
similarity or this analog with
climate change is that we can't just
undo what we've done at least in that in
a very simple fashion right
you know look at how we're now thinking
about how do we do
carbon sequestration how do we you know
take carbon out of this out of the air
right how do we undo these things and
it's and it's very hard it's easy it was
easy to go in one direction it's very
hard to go in the other direction
and
in that sense at least um you know you
know it's always dangerous with
analogies but at least in that sense
and you know on its way to agi may be
similar in that sense which is we can't
always quite get
to undo it in a simple fashion
are you concerned or worried that we
will use ai technology in the way that
we've used
fossil fuel technologies such that we
don't factor in the negative effects or
negative externalities of the use of
that technology so if with ai there is
this deployment of single objective
maximizing algorithms that don't take
account all of our other values and that
actually run over and increase human
suffering
for example the ways in which
youtuber facebook algorithms work to
manipulate and capture attention
do you have a concern that
you know our society has a natural
proclivity towards
learning from mistakes from ignoring
negative externalities until it reaches
sort of a critical threshold
i do worry about that and maybe this to
come back to one of your i think central
uh concerns back to the idea of
incentives i do worry about that in the
sense that
you know
they're going to be such overwhelming
and compelling incentives to deploy ai
systems you know
for for both good reasons
and for the
economic reasons that go with that so
there's lots of good reasons to deploy
ai technology but it's actually great
technology right look at what it's
probably going to do to you know in the
case of health science and breakthroughs
we could make there in climate science
itself in
scientific discovery and materials so
there's lots of great reasons to get
excited about ai and i am right because
it will help us solve
many many problems could create enormous
bounty and
you know benefits for our society right
so we're gonna you know people are gonna
be racing ahead to do that for those
reasons for those very good and very
compelling reasons they're also gonna be
a lot of very compelling economic
reasons right uh the kinds of you know
innovations that companies can make the
kind of you know
contributions to their economic
performance of of of companies
the the kinds of
economic benefits in in the possibility
that ai will contribute to productivity
growth as we talked about before so
there's lots of reasons to
want to go full steam ahead and a lot of
incentives will be aligned to encourage
that right both the
the breakthrough innovations that are
good for society as i said the
the you know the benefits that companies
will get from deploying and using ai in
terms of innovations the
economy-wide productivity benefits so
all good reasons
and i think in the rush to do that we
may in fact find that we're not paying
enough attention not because anybody's
you know is out of malice or anything
like that but we just may not be paying
enough attention
to these other considerations that we
should have alongside right cons you
know considerations about what does this
mean for bias and fairness what does it
mean for potentially for inequality we
know these things have scale superstar
effects what does that mean for
others who get left behind right what
does this mean for the labor markets and
jobs and so forth so i think
we're going to need to find mechanisms
to make sure that you know
this continued but you know substantial
effort at those kind of uh other sides
of the side effects of uh you know of ai
and some of the unintended consequences
that's why at least i think
many of us and you know uh you know are
trying to think about this question of
you know
what are the things we have to get right
uh you know in even as we race towards
all the wonderful things we want to get
out of it uh what are the other things
we need to make you know make sure we're
getting right along the way and how do
we make sure these things are
people are working on them they're
funded uh you know there's you know
there's support for people working on
these other problems i think that's
going to be quite important and we
should not lose sight of that and that's
something i'm concerned about
so let's pivot here then into inequality
and bias
um
could you explain
the risk and degree to which ai may
contribute to
new inequalities or exacerbate existing
inequalities
well i think on the inequality point
it's part of what we talked about before
right which is
uh
you know the fact that you know even
though we may not lose jobs in the near
term um we may you know end up with a
you know creating jobs or complementing
jobs in a way that have these wage
effects that could worsen the inequality
question so that's that's one
way in which ai can contribute to to
inequality the other way of course is
the fact that
uh
you know because of the scale effects
of of these technologies you could end
up with a few companies or a few
entities or a few countries
uh having the ability to develop and
deploy and get the benefits of ai what
the other companies or countries and
places don't so you've got that kind of
inequality uh concern now some of that
could be helped by the way as it is
because it is you know you know it was
the case that you know it has been the
case so far that
uh the the kind of compute capacity
needed to develop and deploy air has
been very very large and the kind of the
data endowments needed to train
algorithms has been very very high but
we know
and and you know the talent of people
who are working these things have been
has been up until now relatively
concentrated but we know that that
picture is changing i think
the you know the advent of cloud
computing which makes it easier for
those who don't have the the compute
capacity is is helping that the fact
that we now have ways to do uh to train
algorithms either with pre-trained
algorithms or other universal models and
others so that not everybody has to
retrain everything every single time so
so
these scarcities and these kind of scale
constraints i think will in those
particulars will get better as we go
forward but you do worry about those
inequalities both in a people sense but
also in a
entity sense
where entities could be companies
countries uh or whole economies i think
the questions of bias are a little bit
different i think the set of questions
of biases just simply has to do with the
fact that
you know up until now um it is so far
anyway um
you know
most of the data sets that have been
used to train these algorithms
often come with societally derived
biases
and emphasizes society-derived bias it's
just because of the way we collect data
and the data that's available and who's
contributing to it so often you start
out with
data sets training datasets that reflect
society's existing biases another the
technology itself has introduced the
bias but in fact these come out of
society and so what the technologies
then do is kind of bake these biases in
into the algorithms and probably deploy
them at scale so that's that's why i
think this question of bias is so
important but i think often it gets
conflated with the fact that well
you know proponents of using these
technologies will say but humans already
have bias in them anyway right we
already make biased decisions etc so of
course that's a
two-sided conversations but at least to
the case you know you know the the
difference that i see between
the biases we have already as human
beings versus
you know the biases that could get baked
into these systems is that these systems
could get deployed at scale right in a
way that if i have biases that i have
and i'm in a room and i'm trying to hire
somebody and i'm you know i'm making my
my biased decisions
at least so hopefully that only affects
that one hiring decision but if i'm
using an algorithm that does these
things by baked in and hundreds of
millions of people are using the
algorithm that we're kind of doing that
in scale so i think
we need to keep that in mind as we have
the debate about you know people already
have biases and sites radio biases
that's true so we need to do work on
that but one of the things i like about
the buyers question by the way
uh with that these technologies are
forcing us to confront is that
it's actually forcing us to really think
about what do you even mean when we say
things are fair
quite aside from technology i think
they're forcing us just like the
uh you know the ubi debate is forcing us
to confront the question that people
don't earn enough to live
the bias questions also forcing us to
confront the question of um
you know
what is fair
right because you know what counts as
fairness uh and i think
all too often i think in our society
we've tended to rely on uh proxies for
fairness right so when we can't define
it we'll say well
let's constitute the right group of
people a diverse enough group of people
and we will trust the decision that they
make because it's a diverse group of
people right so yeah if there's if that
group is diverse in the way we expected
then gender or racial or any other
social income terms and they make a
decision we'll trust it because the
deciding group is is diverse that's just
a you know fairness by proxy in my view
right who knows what those people
actually think and how they make
decisions that's all simple matter but
we trust it because it's a diverse group
the other thing that we've tended to
rely on is you know we trust the process
right so if we trust the process that
hey if it's gone through a process like
this we will live with the results
because we think that a process like
that is fair and unbiased who knows
whether the process is actually fair and
we that's how we've typically done with
our
you know with our you know legal system
for the most part that you know if you
follow through you know if you've been
given due process and you've gone
through a jury trial then it must be
fair we'll live with the results but i
think in in in all of those cases
their
well their useful construct for us
constructs for us is society they still
somewhat avoid
defining what is actually fair and i
think when we start to deploy
technologies where in the cases of ai
the process is somewhat opaque because
we we have this kind of explainability
challenge with these technologies so the
process is kind of black boxy in that
sense
and if we automate the decisions of the
north humans involved then we can't rely
on this constituent group that hey the
group of people decided this so it must
be fair
so
this is forcing us to come back to the
age old or even millennial old question
of what is fair how do we define
fairness um
i think there's some work that was done
before somebody's trying to come up with
all kinds of definitions of fairness and
they came up with
something like 21 um
so so i think we now are having an
interesting conversation about what
constitutes a constitutes fairness i
think
you know do we do we gather data
differently
do we uh
code differently do we have reviews
differently do we have different people
develop the technologies differently do
we have different participants so
we're still grappling with this question
what counts as fair i think that's one
of the key questions is technology as we
as we rely more and more on these uh
technologies to assist uh in some cases
eventually take over some of our
decision-making uh of course only when
it's appropriate these questions will
continue to persist and will only grow
on how do we think about fatness and
bias
so in in terms of fairness bias equality
and and beneficial outcomes with
technology and ai in the 21st century
how do you view the need for and path to
integrating developing countries voices
in the use and deployment of ai systems
well i think there i don't know if
there's any magical
answers uh lucas at some level at a base
level uh we should
have them participate
right i think there's there's this
there's this um
any participation both in the
development and deployment i think is
going to be important and i think that's
true for
developing countries i think it's true
for
uh
parts of even u.s society that's often
not participating in these things i mean
it's still striking to me how
you know
how
you know the lack of diversity
uh in diversity in every sense of the
term right um there is in you know who
is developing ai and who's deploying ai
whether you look within the united
states or around the world right the
entities and places and communities and
whole countries that are not really part
of this so i think we're going to need
to find ways to to do that and i think
part of doing that is
at least for me starts out the
recognition that you know
capability and intelligence are
equally distributed everywhere i don't
think there's any one place or country
or community that has a as a natural
advantage to capability and you know and
and and intelligence so
on on that premise we just need to get
people from different places
participating in the development and
deployment and even the decision making
that's that's related to ai
and not just you know
go with the places where
the the money and the resources happen
to be and that's who's racing ahead uh
both within countries eg in the united
states itself
or
uh in other countries that are being
left behind so i think participation
in in these different ways i think it's
going to be quite quite important
if there's anything you'd like to leave
the audience with
in terms of perspective on the 21st
century on economic development and
technology what is it that you would
would share as a takeaway
well i think if i when i when i look
ahead to the 21st century i
you know i i mean i mean
i'm in two minds on the one hand i'm
actually incredibly excited uh about the
possibilities i think you know we're
just at the beginning of what these
technologies both in ai and so forth but
also in in the life sciences and biotech
i think the the possibilities uh in the
21st change are going to be enormous
possibilities for both
improving human life
uh improving economic prosperity you
know growing economies
uh the the opportunities the you know
just enormous whether you're a company
whether you're a country whether you're
a society the possibilities are just
enormous i think
there's more that lies ahead than behind
at the same time though i think you know
alongside pursuit of those opportunities
are the
the really complicated challenges we're
going to need to navigate through right
so
even as we pursue the opportunities that
ai and these technologies are going to
bring us we're going to need to pay
attention uh to some of these challenges
that we just talked about
these questions are potentially
inequality and bias that comes out of
the deployment of these technologies
the some of the superpower effects that
could come out of that
uh even as we pursue economic
opportunities around the world uh we're
gonna need to think about what happens
you know to poor developing countries
who may not keep up with that or be part
of that how do we so so in every case
you know for all the things that i'm
excited about about the 21st century
which there's plenty there are also
these
challenges along the way we're going to
need to deal with and and and also the
fact that you know society i think
demands more from all of us right it
demands uh i think the demands for a
more
equal and just society are only going to
grow the demands or desires to have a
more inclusive and participative economy
are only going to grow as they should
so we're going to need to be working
both
both sets of problems pursuing the
opportunities because without them
these other problems only get harder by
the way i mean try solving inequality
when there's no economic surpluses right
good luck with that right so
the other these
so we have to solve both we can't pick
one side or the other we have to solve
both at the same time i think we also
need to
deal with some of the potentially
existential challenges that we have and
may grow i mean we we are living through
one right now i mean we're to have more
pandemics in the future than we have
we've had perhaps in the past so we're
just going to need to be ready for that
we've got to deal with climate change
and these kind of public health
climate change issues i think are
global there for all of us these are not
these are no challenges for any one
country uh or any one community and we
we have to kind of work on all of these
together so that set of challenges i
think is for everybody for all of us
it's you know on on planet earth so
we're going to need to work on those
things too so that's kind of at least
how i think about what lies ahead we
have to pursue the opportunities there's
tons of them i'm very excited about that
we have to solve the challenges that
come along with pursuing those
opportunities and we have to deal with
the things that these collective
challenges that we have
i think those are all things to look
forward to
wonderful james thank you so much it's
really interesting and and perspective
shifting if uh any of the audience is
interested in following you or checking
your work out anywhere where the best
places to do that
if you search my name and search
mckinsey global institute you'll see
some of the research and papers that i
you know i referenced and for those who
love data which i do uh and you know
these are very data rich uh kind of fact
based perspectives so that's the just
look at the mckinsey global institute
website all right thank you very much
james
oh you're welcome thank you
[Music]